ما ترونه هو
الاستثناء في دوله غير عضو في الاتحاد
الاوروبي يجتمع وزراء خارجيه التكتل جاؤوا
الى اوكرانيا لاجلها في خطوه تاريخيه بدت
بالغه الدلاله مستقبل كيف في الاتحاد
الاوروبي يقول ممثل السياسه الخارجيه
للاتحاد جوزيب بوريل يقترح الرجل تقديم
حزمه تسهيلات ماليه لكيف بقيمه خه مليارات
يورو يريد التزاما
اقوى بالتاكيد اقوى الالتزامات الامنيه
التي يمكننا تقديمها لاوكرانيا هي عضويه
الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا اقوى التزام امني
لاوكرانيا الان اوكرانيا دوله مرشحه
للعضويه وهي تمضي الى ما ابعد من ذلك في
هذا
الطريق اذا كان تاكيد مواصله الدعم الغربي
للاوكرانيين الرساله الابرز للاجتماع
الوزاري الاوروبي فانه ليس من بد من فهم
السياق والتوقيت واضح ان اعباء الحرب تثقل
كواهل
الحلفاء لن تعدم في الصف الاوروبي اصواتا
متدمره من قتال يستنزف الجهد
والمال هذه سلوفاكيا المندفعه يسارا
الفائز في انتخاباتها التشريعيه المبكره
له مقاربه مختلفه لدعم
اوكرانيا انه حزب الديمقراطيه الاجتماعيه
قياده رئيس الوزراء الاسبق روبرت فيكو
المتجه لتشكيل حكومه ائتلافيه يريد الحزب
وقف المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا وينتقد
الاتحاد الاوروبي ويعارض مساعي كيف
للانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي يدعو الحزب
في المقابل الى تحسين العلاقات مع روسيا
تماشيا مع المزاج العام للشعب
السلوفاكي المزاج المتغير في الجوار
الاوكراني تجسده ايضا بولندا رئيس وزرائها
قال ان بلاده ستوقف دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا
لصالح تعزيز قوتها الدفاعيه هو التحول
الوشيك اذا في السياسات الخارجيه والامنيه
لكل من براتيسلافا ووارسو قبل هذه وتلك
ثمه واشنطن الداعم القادم من بعيد حتى
المساعده الامريكيه لاوكرانيا صار يلفها
الغموض يقول الرئيس الامريكي انه لا يمكن
السماح بقطع الدعم عن
الاوكرانيين مع ذلك اغفل الكونجرس
المساعدات الماليه لكيف في مشروع قانون
الميزانيه المؤقت الذي اقره لتجنب اغلاق
حكومي في ذلك وغيره اشارات تتلقفها موسكو
يقول الكرملين ان ما وصفه بتعب الغرب من
تمويل كيف سيزداد وانه سيؤدي الى تفكك
النخب السياسيه وانقسام الراي العام
الغربي ازاء
اوكرانيا